i saw in the news today
talking about the violence in foreign
countries
[Music]
talking about all the savagery up in the
world
but they
never talk about south central
they never talk about what happened to
my brother
now he's gone
now i ain't got no brother
yo dog
i'll be your brother
really
absolutely dark
you're gonna need somebody to lean on
you can't just be walking around here
where there's emptiness in your heart
man an emptiness that can only
be filled
by a brother
okay
brothers man
brother
[Music]
you keep following me around man why
don't you go home and stay out of my
room nobody don't mess with my models
i'm about to get away
[Music]
hey
you don't give a grown man a wedgie
[__] i'm 34 years old
oh
[Applause]
upside down son
it's it's to the side a little bit too
oh bro
my bad dog my bad dog you want to keep
doing it let's go
yeah man i'm just i'm saying yo be
careful i got you dog i got you
what's up straight down the middle son
you can't go back middle now son what we
already committed to the upside down and
to the side
what are you doing man you said upside
down and to the side that's three omegas
oh man i forgot the pie
[Music]
oh
oh man i mean you know that like the
deck man like that sticker rocket ship
or or a lighthouse
nah man you straight up got it on your
chest
to the man of the hour
guys
best bachelor party ever
oh yeah yeah
[Applause]
i can still do it all right bella yes
what do you say
we get a stripper
tray i told you man no strippers uh is
this a bachelor party or isn't it that's
what i'm talking about i'm your best man
there's no way i'm gonna let you puss
out on your own bachelor party we're
getting a stripper and we're gonna
connect the dots yes
yeah
tinker toy it man you're behind her and
then we all bup up up up we go to town
hold up hold up hold up hold up no
what's the
bump yeah yeah what is that guys
this is tommy's last night of freedom
yeah come on what what's bubba pup
though
you know
okay okay okay when you say
are we what are we are we all linked up
yeah
baby elephant walk woo
okay okay okay um
are you saying
that that we would we would all be
each other
you don't understand us
oh dude okay look here it is okay
you're
the girl right right right yeah then
we bump up
right there yeah yeah i'm not doing that
you guys
tommy's about to walk the plank of
marriage all right this is our last
chance a chance for what i'm not gonna
[__] a guy yeah no dude we'd all be
the girl oh
okay yeah
together
right there that's right that's the
weird part the bop okay i get it i get
it
you don't want to be disrespectful to
women i get that okay the issue forget
the girl armenian conveyor belt just the
groom and his groomsmen blah blah blah
blah blah no
you don't kept the part that nobody
wants
yeah i definitely don't want to have sex
with any of you guys yeah you're killing
my buzz guys what the [__]
man this is supposed to be tommy's last
big celebration no judgment judgment is
not what is keeping us from each other
jeez forget it no i'm saying guys if you
listen to my words tommy's in here
stripper we're in the other room
the stripper the rest of us is just
cheeky
oh cheeky god you guys are so gay
[Music]
right there
unlocked
you ain't going nowhere getting five
you're gonna
oh
dude how we gonna break the world record
if you can't keep it up
it is so good to see you keith
yeah we usually have to wait for a
special occasion well actually i have a
little surprise i
got engaged
yes
wow
congratulations little bro
engaged
kind of a big deal
more for me i guess that's what that
means
yeah it's about um
she got a name
stephanie marriage
is a wonderful journey 50 and the
divorce
sorry bro
them's just the facts
i will uh we'll keep that in mind thank
you
you got a photo oh yeah aka does she
exist there you go
oh she is beautiful
let me get eyes on this
everybody else already ha
great lighting
airbrushed i know
she kind of looks like that one model uh
on the price is right uh yes
uh that's her
the price is right clive that's your
show shut up mom no it's not
uh
stephanie
people always under-bid on their
showcases not the best presenter
[Music]
where's the wedding oh uh in hawaii
oh
awesome
she ever been married before uh no so
she says
ex-boyfriends you got one
of course sloppy seconds at least right
dad
keith she sounds wonderful
shut up
mom
silence from you
okay you're cut off
from talking
you know what clive
i really don't appreciate the way that
you're talking to mom
yes
the prodigal son hath returned you know
what you want to go let's go cause i've
been here for the last 15 years taking
care of mom and dad well you've been
trollopsing all over the world and why
so you can come back here and criticize
me for how i treat them no
i actually came here
to ask you if you would do me the honor
of being my best man
i know that we have uh
had our differences
but you're my older brother
we'll pay for your room
and we're also going to rent you a car
and we'll pay to fly you out there
first class
well we can't afford first class
you're dead to me
why shut up
i'm eating in my room
well that uh that went better than
expected
i think so
yeah
and i felt sorry for that dude but you
know what you gonna do i had to lay that
down
what didn't lay you down hey brother i
don't know what fight you was at then
you got a couple licks in sure but
i was like
man i put the [__] on the chain wax
[__] on the chain wax
is that a thing
well yeah that yeah that's a that's a
thing yeah yeah that's something
okay yeah i put the [__]
[Applause]
i just um google [__] on the chain wax
no results man um
why are you googling no i'm just saying
[__] on the chain wax
it's not an expression
yeah it is yes thank you it's something
leo yeah what what what does it mean
then what does it mean
i'll tell you what it means it means
that
is that you put the [__] on it
because
y'all know what it is okay have either
the two of you have you ever said the
words [__] on the chain wax in any
context
us
he talking you man you ain't talking to
me dude
hey man it's not our fault that you
ain't never put that [__]
no one can put the [__] on the chain
wax cause [__] on the chain wax ain't a
thing
you trying to start a thing aren't you
what
kids
i mean
what are you talking about trying to
start a thing a thing like off the hook
or i'm gonna put you on blast you trying
to get it in the effort so everybody out
there saying [__] on the chain wax man
why are you doing this why are you
looking at what i'm saying and and fact
checking my ass
you keep saying some
that doesn't exist
and you got thing one and thing two
corroborating your story like it does
and you why are you lying there it's
[__]
[Music]
why do you care so much
whether i made up
[__] on the chain wax
or not
[Music]
i lost my job
my girl left me
and all i all i wanted to do
was have a little bit of fun
[Music]
with my friends today so why why do you
ha why do you have to belittle me like
that
[Music]
it's just that i yeah
i'm just trying to say what you trying
to say
i'm trying to say
that i want to put the [__]
[Applause]
roommate meeting
roommate meeting go go what the hell
i've got to hang over i don't give a
[__] about your hangover okay brendon i
want a roommate meeting i want it now
okay
now somebody's been taking
out of the refrigerator and throwing it
on the ground and it's pissing me off is
this another one of your stupid pranks
donald no and your pranks are stupid is
it you monday what
i said somebody's been taking
out of the fridge and throwing it on the
ground and i want to know who it is
because it's not funny well what i want
to know is who keeps pulling the sheets
off my bed and hanging them from the
ceiling fan at night was that you monday
what have you been taking everybody's
sheets off of them in the night and
hanging them from the ceiling fans
what no well clearly someone's been
doing that
whoa
who did that yeah
who the [__] did that which one of you
just proved that by what are we even
talking about right now did you [__]
throw that bottle donald no go go
ew i didn't throw it but then you can
throw that bottle brenden yeah
you would do that friendy dude no i
didn't draw the bottle well somebody
threw that [__] bottle and you're the
one who drew dicks on everyone's
forehead yeah you did do that the dicks
were hilarious though this is just
destructive what about you monday did
you throw that bottle
what bottle the [__] bottle dude it
just smashed against the wall and you
even said something about it
well i didn't throw a bottle well
obviously it wasn't ping he's got the
best grades in the house
good point ping come on guys let's cool
it with the profanity you know things
very religious
[Music]